okay so uh format is 11 3 minute games
and then 10 one minute games so 21 games
total
um i won't be looking at chat
i'll probably have alerts turned on
unless they get too distracting
but uh yeah let's send the challenge
we'll make it rated random color
i think my opponent's higher rated than
me actually
for fellow i am
okay oh i guess we both sent a challenge
okay good luck to my opponents
okay chad is going bye-bye um
e4 i'm trying to remember what i
prepared
i did some very like brief preparation
but nothing too intensive
oh he's gonna go into taimana probably i
guess
yeah he plays g3
i'll play the line with um another s6
and h5
i think i probably have a few games in
the database
like over the board tournament database
some idea of taking bishop here and
knight g4
ah but then there's bishop f4 let's just
go for it
bishop four is a strong move here which
he knows
that's unfortunate so i have queen here
how bad is this i have e maybe d6
actually
queen still attacked and e5 coming
yeah the problem is white's going to
have a long-term
kind of positional edge
i'm going to have to play this move in
bishop e6
i'm gonna try and conserve time
oh some idea rook here
still looming ideas of uh pushing the
h-pawn
this looks decent so we could trade
everything
like takes takes takes takes takes takes
it is nice so that uh this bishop is
stronger than this bishop
because this pawn is fixed on a light
square
oh are we actually training everything
this pawn could be weak in the end
like takes takes takes takes knight a4
but then knight g7
and knight d7 oh f4 is an interesting
move
and so what to do here
go play b5
and just leave all the tension
if it takes i play this and went back
upon if this i have to
do some dancing around
yeah f4 was uh was nifty
not sure rook d1
d1 maybe king c8 i'm just nervous like
rook d1 king c7
takes here in knight d5 maybe king maybe
king b7 it's okay
yeah rook d1 i probably play king c7 and
this is 3-0 so time is
it's not like 3-2 which i just played
time is a lot more important
interesting so i could take and play e4
because he can't take his rook there or
rookie eight let's do this
now i'll probably just defend the pawn
and try and win this pawn eventually
the king wants to come in but it's not
easy
that's a good move
play this with bishop f1 never mind
let's defend the pawn so the king wants
to come here
first thanks for all your content
oh thank you really enjoyed shady finn
appreciate that
yeah so i can't it's interesting we
can't take each other's pawns even
though we want to
have this move
let's play this first not what i want to
do
but what else b3 is a move
now let's just go for this
here's some idea rook c8 and then this
i can take with check
not sure though
i'm just going for g5
gotta get those g5 emotes
can do your king e5 now
it's pleasant i'm not sure his speed
skills
ooh can move
pawns week let's go for this
yeah this should be winning
okay that was nice nice conversion
managed my time yeah thanks again uh
whoever that was
finney something oh and pit uh pipinator
something with prime
appreciate that okay
and that's nerve-wracking it's only the
first game
i'll play um i'll probably play london
here
i did a little bit of prep in this i
know he um he's gonna allow h5 and then
he'll play c5
and i think he plays this in this so i
prepared knight d2
bishop g4 is another line
i should i should have been more
thorough my prep
and usually bishop e2 is the way to go
but this is also a move
and play vision e2
no no lights pinned what am i thinking
about
so the the main idea was to play knight
d2 knight b3
so i'm calculating this takes and king
takes e2
upon cloud style
it's probably just bad but
i don't immediately see what's wrong
with it
it's queen a6 king 1
e5 bishop g3
i'm going with my first instinct and
this is probably really bad though
and the whole idea is to play knight b3
so
after takes knight b3 queen here and
then i take the pawn
oh there's queen c4 i guess queen d3
that's equal material
the problem is e5 is coming e5
it's not so bad though
or maybe it is really bad e5 visual g3
there's some queen queen g4 could hurt
me
there's bishop each no bishop a69 g4
i have to defend f2 here
yeah this is an opening gone terribly
wrong akini 2 is probably
a big no-no probably even 92.
i'm fighting have some
time advantage oh that's a good move
well that's a really good move
i could take and play knight c5 maybe
get some counter play
as if takes i play this b7 could fall
there's some idea of also e5 is hanging
probably 94.
it's got to get the pieces into play so
lingering ideas of this and take and
take
and now the benefit is if ever this i
take i um
put the rook here and then take on c4
okay
so rookie 8's expected i take
maybe i just go for a3 because if none
of the knight takes i trap the knight
am i not winning a pawn here he's gonna
take
i guess it's the fair trade
jakes i trapped the knights and i'll
bring my knight back to e4 it's a very
nice square
some idea of this and this so if rook
here i
was basically forking the pawn and
forking the fork
looks nice time is nice
yeah there's no increment either oh it's
another raid it's just sweden
thanks chef sweden thanks for the match
some really fun games
um yeah if you're just joining this is
uh this is a bit more serious of a match
or we're into the the second game
position is very nice
time is very nice should win this
without too much issue
take a thing
oh he resigned he resigned very timely
okay
okay two out of two let's go
maybe i'll mix up the opening a little
bit
yeah let's mix up the opening
i play this as uh
as white i'll play this line knight a5
and a6 b5
it's just a line to get out of uh of
theory
trying to maybe win a pawn or maybe not
i want to be civil here
knight f6 here's e5
i could play like d6 and just kind of
shiven again
i'll play bishop c5
looks interesting so i'm basically
developing the queen side first
and the knight really wants to come to
e5 eventually another knight can also
maybe communicate
it's all about having the pieces
communicate with each other
and bishop e3 there's some ideas of this
ooh
so pawnee five that's probably a really
strong move
yeah because 94 is coming if i take the
the knight has to take i have d5 there
maybe it's okay it takes takes
thanks for something by the way prosper
appreciate that
yeah so 94 bishop c7
that's just about castling before
getting mated
d8 coming good move
97 bishop g5 so there's this idea
which i might go for
queen d2 rook d8 in the end
i just want to trade queens
my time is kind of suffering
okay that's a nice move to see
some idea 96
i think things are under control but
it's it's shaky
bishop side down bishop's side down to
two things actually
but this doesn't work i don't think this
does much
of 95 here
so blocking the rook
the queen is also tied down to the
knights kind of
take the pawn there's rook c1
knight d4 coming
i'm gonna have to suffer knight d4
probably queen v6
[Music]
this is not good i could take
now what do i do here take take
97
this is really bad time wise position
wise
24 i guess
ah
rook c1 coming and queen a2 being greedy
he's going to sag on e6 and destroy me
but what to do
is kind of attacked oh i'm getting mated
right it's like forced me somehow
i'm just hoping he forgets about f2 or
he forgets about this time
it maybe it just doesn't see e7s hanging
it's an easy knight g7 or knight c7 just
destroys me
gotta try though
always gotta fight
ah i tried i tried
i was rough though he played well
what opening was that oh yeah that was a
weird like um
95 line
i'll play e4 mix it up a little bit more
also play knight c3
okay i'm gonna apply the same same
opening
yeah this is a line i've been playing
since uh
i was pretty young i tricked uh fidel
corralese in this
other day not h6 is the best move
so 96 it's a sign like he knows what
he's doing he wants to play this so i
play this
idea is to play this takes in this
so i'm basically preventing my g4 if d6
i play h3
i just want to get some nice development
this is playable gets close to balanced
he wants to play f5
i can play this threatening to win a
pawn because now the bishop's overworked
f5 i take take take
yeah it's very logical
so again i'm threatening to win the pawn
expecting this
i kind of want to play f4 here
this f5 is coming
what else to play
i mean there's h3 like prophylaxis
at 4 is kind of interesting though for
knight g4 h3
so f4 f5 i take
there's bishop takes
could just castle this castle make him
think
f f5 i probably blitz out bishop g5 and
then
decide whether i go for this or this
and probably a four
it's risky like he's it's risky for both
of us so
like we're both trying to get something
on the king side
and obviously in the center too
but my rook is my last rook is quicker
to come into the game
than his rook but he might be getting
the bishop hair
yes i can play this
it takes i take with queen
a good move
i like my bishop bishop is nicely placed
some idea f5
that was very logical
my knight is really misplaced
we play f5 here
might be the way to go there's also
knight g3 then f5
actually let's play f5 here
i'm just trying to get a situation of
like good knight versus bad bishop
so if i ever can get an outpost of five
that would be the dream could take maybe
takes takes takes
a tricky move
me this move
got my time
knight g3 incoming
gonna be another scramble
at least he's thinking here
he has three summer pawns i have no
center pawns
queen c6 maybe maybe not
in a good position
some hope
let's go he's so close to mating me when
i'm listening him
i actually don't know what's going on
after king g8
i might be losing the final position wow
came down the time wow okay three to one
let's go
i'm not sure what to play he's been
playing the same
kind of thing i could play g6
i play this line as white but i don't
play knight f3
huh
yeah this is new for me
i actually don't know what to do here um
probably d6
also some a6 idea
i should know my openings better
so i mean he wants to play e5
i guess i'll play d6 can't be that bad
yeah he's definitely still in prep
ah i think 97 is interesting
just gambit yolo gambit
i'm pretty sure he would be prepared
after takes so
i might as well get him out of his his
comfort zone just sack a pawn for an
easier position
thanks for stopping whiff and meister
appreciate that
[Music]
yeah like this sort of time control is
so important to get
positions which are just easier to play
even if they're objectively not so great
um i'd much rather be like down the pawn
but have an easy position rather than
just being defending
the whole time
that's probably not that bad like the
queen's a target
yeah take my pawns he takes twice i play
rook here and the bishop comes to life
yeah that's a decent move
so i can play this queen might swing
over
i assume he's gonna take or not
so i could take with the queen
and bishop h6 is coming
interesting idea bishop here and then
queen b4
it's actually hard for white to avoid
the queen trade
i should have chad open i forgot about
that
okay let's play this move
so idea of just trading
and getting some playable position
i'm also actually threatening to take
and win material i think
it's probably gonna fizzle into some
like equal
ish position probably gonna come down to
time again
now the queen really doesn't have
another square there's queen g3
but again queen g3 i take and i guess
there's takes
i think he's taking time because after
the line takes takes c2 is actually kind
of annoying
for white to defend so we counter
attacks very logical
bishop here
yeah let's trade try and keep the time
advantage [ __ ] about five comes
oh that's a good move though because
takes rook c1
have to move back
ah lose a pawn in the end of that line
about what else to do c4 let's actually
go for this
good move
okay losing a pawn
maybe getting counter play
[Music]
please play rook d1 please
you see statics
ah that was bad
let's go
no
ah well played
oh very well played i dropped the rook
i was too focused on yeah i forgot this
was a resource
well played okay still ahead
what to play he's playing this bishop g4
line
you play against sicilian
i'll mix it up still
i'll probably play the line with knight
f3
it's interesting oh okay so he's
deviating so let's take him play off f4
i was going to say that he's been very
consistent with his openings
i didn't really do too much prop
i looked at his what he plays and he
plays a lot of different things
so i was expecting him to deviate more
i play this move basically forces him to
take on f3
let's do it don't want to hesitate too
much i can lift the rook maybe
oh it's nice after takes takes queen d4
i can take
i didn't see that ahead of time but
okay so things are kind of under control
oh yeah rooks move sideways
can't really take
rook rook f4 is interesting
i mean rookout 4 might be the way to go
there's also queen g3 queen g3 queen d4
bishop e3
what else to play
yeah let's go for this there's not h5 i
mean it's
very possible black will win a pawn
oh there's bishop d4 now
i can't even i can't take on c5
um i'll probably have to just
lose material and fight for counter play
not a good position not a good time
situation either thank you anaximander
appreciate that
um if i take
not the happiest of positions i have g4
i mean to to not loses i have to make
things crazy
and not exactly what i want
so i'm down i'm down two pawns basically
oh the rook's gonna have a square no
matter what
okay let's trade
not looking good
i got to go for activity though so i'm
stacking the d-pawn
[Music]
hopes of somehow doing something against
this
[Music]
king wants to come in
okay so now i'm attacking this and this
i mean this is
ah this is not what i want
take that and take this
i'll try a stalemate trap type thing
yeah well played ah so i ran into
trouble
i guess after rook before it was
difficult position
okay so that was okay i was six games
tied three to three
and it's been a good fight so far
just have to stay very very focused
strong opponent
oh is he taking a break
oh he needs to okay he's taking a break
so real quick let's analyze
did i miss anything obvious in this
position
so e5 was just bad yeah
yeah usually white wants to go for this
setup but it was a bit too slow
oh thanks for the bits again to sends
critic
yeah i'm putting more focus on at least
we have like a group chat and then we
have this game chat
yeah thanks again to naximander selling
for eight months
and okay let's close the chat again
um maybe i'll mix it up
what to play
i'll play g6 i'll play maybe a norwegian
rat
like this and then this um
or we'll just have like a pierce
oh bishop f4 wait this is what i play
um there's some h5 move like h5 and then
new stuff
i don't play this too often though
i play this more from the white side
at least it's interesting e5 was maybe
not the best thing
to allow
actually how bad is this i don't even
have nine h5 here
uh i could sack a pawn
yeah i have to sack a pawn
oh that's a fancy move
oh this is really bad or is it
it's probably really bad
it's actually really bad uh
wondering can i play nigh that fades no
then bishop b5 i have to take
yeah suffering the consequences but what
to do
i have three cyberpuns e5 ideas
something to work with
yeah there weren't too many ways to
defend e6
also white was finding a fork i'm
actually threatening to attack both
bishops
with e5
yeah this is an opening gone terribly
terribly wrong
but there's still hope
wow oh that's a cool move so i have to
stay defending the pawn
oh but queen f4 is coming i have to play
this
i know their choice bishop f6
still kind of alive
i still want to play this or not
so this this move
i just want to trade queens okay
i'm just winning a piece
oh forgot about that move
it's still okay though let's play this
position
i pawns he's alpha pawn
i have i've seen my center i have the
bishop pair
uh there's rook g8 here
e4 is also kind of interesting i think
i'll start with rook g8
should be six takes takes
maybe i should start with king
[Music]
ah my time okay
just gotta play quick
difficult position ob choose a target
though
i'm controlling the center
that's something right
i should have taken the pawn
let's go
that's what it takes to win games just
gotta be fast and not flag and not lose
okay i'll repeat the london line we had
earlier
thanks for uh for support vinnie chase
appreciate it yeah so we're going into
the same line as earlier i'm gonna play
queen d2 this time
wait it's taken then knight f3 and then
queen d2
i should really know this better
what to do
yeah so here maybe knight d4
[Music]
knight d4 is interesting
i might just get severely punished
i'm realizing i should not go into this
line again
i just want to go for like this idea
and here actually if queen c5 then
knight b3 i think wins upon
because unlike previously my king's not
an e2 my bishop's controlling the
diagonal
so here here here i win the pawn and
attack the queen
i'm just scared of stuff with this this
this
but maybe it's it's not a big deal like
this i take
actually maybe this because takes i i
lose one of the things
probably take with bishop takes and then
c3 nice kind of pawn chain
and bishop c4 in the end
so we're not going into that
interesting i have a3 here
and then knight takes d5
okay maybe f3
what else to do
actually the position is still kind of
difficult because b2 is hanging
rook d8 is coming
ooh oh this is still very difficult i
have bishop d3
that's probably the way to go just go
for like insta
attack
i mean i'm two moves away from mating
there's some crazy idea kingdy too to
prepare the rook sack
not sure if it works but just another
resource
actually if takes on b2 then the queen
could be a
eventual target as well
okay rook d i probably play queen c4
or queen oh the queen doesn't have so
many squares
and queen g5 actually
oh but rook takes d3 oh there's a cool
line
here here and then takes an attack and
i think it's okay
i could queenside castle here
because the idea is after takes takes
takes i play queen g6 and
take on d3 with a rook so i don't think
i'm losing anything unless i
am oh there's bishop b2
that should be okay
as h5 is nice that's one of the benefits
of playing this opening
i'm hoping i'm not plundering anything
over the one i can take with king
very important that's good my king's not
on b1
and rook t1 would be great for black
and the time is looking good
okay
okay that was nice felt good about that
um i might repeat that line actually his
knight t4 idea
because he really i guess he was on one
thinking most of the game
i'll repeat this
play a6
i have a feeling he's going to transpose
into open never mind
so we have one of these
and this is pretty yeah one of those
moves
i can take oh thanks toggy well it's
talking
yeah i have the event list still turned
on so i can see some sort of alerts
but yeah no more tts for this stream
at least while i'm playing
oh
how dangerous is this
i guess i'll find out knight h5 g6
bishop h6
i move the rook it's probably really
dangerous
oh there's a cool idea here here here
knight here
takes none here threatening this and
this
the queen e4 but still right here
night's still hanging in that line
i probably still end up down the
exchange
at least he's the one thinking
my moves are kind of natural anyway
yeah i really want to make this work
this 95 idea
i guess i have f5 as oh f5 is actually
really nice
so bishop h6 just f5
and then i guess there's queen c4
queen c4 takes takes and then this
actually looks okay
okay one more time f5 queen c4 takes
takes there
bishop takes off faith that's no biggie
let's do it
okay this is similar
there's rook f7 okay so we're going into
this
end game
um
i take with king and then queen d7
oh let's do this queen f7
that's a fancy move i have queen d7 she
probably missed
i almost missed that move too
okay so actually material is like equal
it's um
rook and pawn for two miners but the two
miners are usually preferable
in these situations
i still got to be careful though
bishop g7 could be a nice
pink and there's also bishop e5
let's start with this idea a4
soon
so
this is really really pleasant oh that's
a nice idea though
i can't take it
maybe you're okay seven
so threatening to take is the knights
defended now
um he's being resourceful
this move so if this i
block i just want to build a blockade
this is nice
so i'm controlling like all the key
squares
let's go for this
let's go for this
really it was probably winning
regardless
okay that was nice i was kind of a clean
was it clean
it got kind of messy like he kind of
went all out for the attack and
i got a better end game
okay
maybe i'll play a close sicilian i
haven't played one of those in a while
just one of these
i might even like delay open sicilian
there's a cool idea is nigel short
knight c1 and then knight d1 and then c3
um this might actually be the same
position nigel had
in his game against hussein
um i'll go for 191 immediately
so he's going to go for like this
expansion
bishop oh no not not bishop h6 but c3
first and then this
it's still like pretty balanced
and he's actually playing this quite
well
i guess f4 is an idea
unless i play f4
it actually looks kind of playable
and then the lights come in kind of
naturally
it's important to keep a pawn on e4 to
restrict the knight
yeah over defending this bishop always
defends e4
oh that's a good move i'm queen h3
which actually pins so it defends and it
pins upon
black would really want to take probably
now threatening to take
f9 f2
this bishop's really annoying though
you rook off too no
[Music]
that doesn't do anything
i mean c4 looks so ugly but i might have
to do it
yeah not what i want but sometimes you
have to
do things that you don't want to do in
life
it's now at least a bishop plot i mean i
weaken the square but the light can jump
in
it's not that bad actually
rook can come in
i might want to play b3 at some point
like b3 i was thinking just here i take
95 as well
yeah so now there's this pin
the queen is tied down to the night as
well
i want to play f5 but the problem is it
just weakens things and it breaks the
pin
as well so i think the best strategy is
to leave tension maybe queen g4 bishop
h3
okay he's solving his issues
it's queen h4 and you know six
let's do some some ideas of f5
f5 takes takes mini king
probably should start with king here
should leave the night superfluous
okay going for it
probably not working though but maybe it
is 94 coming
attacking stuff knight g5 is a massive
threat
oh my g5 queen moves f7 and then
whatever it takes i mate
should be winning
i'll just leave the queen attacked
oh forgot about that ah
okay another time scramble
this is just made in two this is made in
two that's nice
okay man these games are stressful
seven to three so we play one more
one more i'll be black and then then we
go into the
um the bullet i think we would probably
take a break between game or between the
stages too i might play e5
i'm trying to remember what he plays he
plays some weird like gambit type thing
i think oh he's thinking what to do
maybe i don't know
i still have chat closed but thank you
chess ninja chess ninja with 800 bits
thanks so much
and t-con with 100 bits and tony with
500 bits
[Music]
um
okay let's play chess ooh
london time
a pleasant surprise
okay so i'll play this sign
rook c8 is a key move so my queen b6
i haven't seen this like bishop e5 and
c3 huh
i'm just gonna go for natural play
yeah he might take an outpost
or that so knight here is like the
one idea at least i have a6 as well
i'm just scared of a6 takes and then b4
it's not so pleasant
i could play queen c7
kind of walks into the same thing though
there's actually a weird idea to take
queen b6 takes takes
i don't see anything wrong with that
it looks weird thanks for subbing by the
way
and yeah i think i i won't take
immediately
once i do let's play this so i'm
temporarily down upon
we'll get some kind of end game
try and go for the queen trade when you
try bishop here
it's okay i gotta be
very watchful of time
now be solid i'll win back the pawn
bishop vs knight
in this move first
knight d4 f5 coming
actually it's not that bad the g4 i play
this first
maybe bishop e4 here
and bishop found a very happy square i'd
like to go for the minority attack
she doesn't want me to do but now i have
another target
someone do a rook b8 b5
i'll keep tickling the pawn it's rookie
okay one expected
i think the king would be
actually let's start with this
the key wants to go here just slowing
down g4
f6 for good measure bam now it's coming
to d4
this move
oh my time
let's go for this
it's a weird position like both all the
rooks are awkward
that's a good move
the time is really bad
my position's not so great either
what to do here
[Music]
how to do something
so rook here i play this
i can win the pawn i just want to get my
center pawns rolling somehow
a6 i take it b6 i think things are under
control
yeah the biggest worry is time
please just think for another 50 seconds
i would be pleased with a draw
even more pleased with a win
this b5 why not
so we're trading
okay draw is a fair result and my time
hacking
uh i was kind of getting outplayed but
okay can't complain too much yeah the
rook ending was uh i think slightly
better for white around here
as these pawns were awkward my rook was
awkward so
let's say three minute break
thanks a moisty cake okay time to focus
oh i was gonna play hall of the mountain
king
uh let me prepare it probably not in
this game but if i need a boost i'll
play it
okay um good luck how do i even play
i'll play the close sicilian line again
i guess oh let me close alert box
there we go okay
okay
i'm gonna go for h4 or not
wait uh can i not take that i can't take
that
h4 is still a cool idea
maybe it's not working
maybe it is working i don't know
it's interesting
i have to take that
it's a solid position i just don't know
what to do
you see four
might be over pushing here
good move um this move
oh that doesn't do anything though
this is really bad
oh it was kind of a time scramble
towards the end okay well played
i'll play um i'll try a stafford maybe
i'll try stafford
okay i need a boost
okay ah don't wanna pre-move f5
mouse about five
interesting
okay let's focus
develop normally
maybe quincy ideal sacking and mating
that's a dream in life let's not blunder
let's take this and b6 and trade more
keep the time advantage
he wants to break through on the queen
side
i want to do things on the king side
i got fate just got to build up pressure
as much as possible
can take all the time
okay i'm taking more
it's not plunder a queen
oh that's a good move can i defend
this move
that's dangerous so i'll have to do that
not so pleasant but i'm still defending
keep defending well does this move let's
go for the attack
what oh okay we're trading
more trades
no ah 35 time
35 time let's go free pawn i like three
pawns
let's go let's go
no yes let's go
[Music]
okay
dirty flag let's go
okay
again
okay grand prix time oh this line again
i remember this line you know so play
knight h6
okay i'm prepared more this time
queen g3 i guess why not
and then probably f4 yeah
making things spicy
maybe idea of taking or just leaving the
tension
okay f5
oh my pawn is weak i could take
oh we trade a lot let's do it
just gotta be quick oh he's getting
center
this isn't good where is it
no this is not good there's a d5 ideas
oh tactics let's go
pin and win
pawn is weak ooh
with no ideas good move
what to play maybe attack the knight i
do this and this
and then this king safety first
c3 oh it doesn't work ah or does it
let's try it yolo
don't hurt me no
you're hurting me
please get forked please
oh you got forked yes i'm still worse
though
another dirty time scramble
[Music]
us
[Music]
what happened that was a draw oh it's a
draw because he queens ah
oh he queen just in time too wow
okay we go again
i wonder want stafford gambit
he's not accepting please just accept
okay reverse scotch
i like this variation nice and
aggressive
a5 prophylaxis defend the pawn control
the center
and don't trade when you have a space
advantage
tickle the pawn idea to maneuver
bishop hair like the bishop hair
let's push gain some space
queen d4 i guess we're just trading
yeah we're just trading
i'll try and keep some time advantage
i can trade some more just want to
provoke a weakness
okay let's defend a weakness
just want to play f5
f5 incoming let's go g5 incoming
yeah omanos
control the file push
all the pawns oh that pawn was hanging
but he didn't take it
oh we're gonna have a a very
peaceful draw maybe
[Music]
okay okay that was anticlimactic but
that's okay
rematch
okay london opening again
oh he's mixing it up playing a king's
indian
preventing e5 though go for the early
bishop h6
so black cat castle
here i play this i always play king b1
this move immediately fiancadoing the
queen
oh it didn't work though oh no my knight
but he doesn't he didn't punish me
so here i do this stuff
ooh this is dangerous
try this don't hurt me
what oh no
uh oh oh no
i have to try this it's not good though
that's really not good i'm the fight
though
my time what happened to my time
ah to go for this
i have no hope or do i where's my hope
[Music]
this is really really bad
i have three seconds left what no
okay no more song i gotta focus let's
focus we're gonna have a silent game
silent game time oh
okay let's play e5 and go into some
normal
opening stuff i'll play bishop b4
bishop before scotch is a simple
approach
okay queen d5
d5 is some idea
it might be terrible but it's
interesting
it's probably more terrible than
interesting unfortunately
i'm trying something a file is kind of
nice
uh he stops me i play rook e8
take and do this just trying to increase
tension
oh good move
that was a really good move
this move
i try and stay active
okay defending the rook
oh bishop c4 is coming good move
yeah thankfully b5 kind of saves me but
not really
or does it i don't know it's complicated
wow i'm alive how am i alive i'm winning
on time too
okay wow i don't know what happened
there i was getting crushed and then
somehow i survived
okay let's go let's play this opening
again
probably repeat the grand prix setup
play this line a new opening variation
i'll keep the position closed because i
have nights
positional
it's probably not necessary but i'm
keeping things simple
i do f4
a nice time advantage too
keep the pressure
cover these squares go for g4
really this move maybe
so now it's running g4 oh that's a good
move wow what a good move um
i'm just losing
i'm trying to trap the knight
now knight's not getting trapped though
so i have to go for a dirty flag
not looking good
and there's still some hope
wow i feel bad about that one he was
beating me the whole game
but that's the nature of bullet i guess
have to just win games for the team
okay so we have another
opening
i feel really dirty about that one
play this move and then probably d5 and
vision e7
oh i'm losing a pawn okay
clear up here first
keep the pressure okay just gain space
here
prevent f4
lift a rook now he really wants to play
f4
but the knights on each one completely
suck
idea queen h3 now oh can't do that
move the pawn just trying to attack
there we go
oh good move that was a really good move
it's going to come down to time again
probably
now this bishop is about to be a hero
hopefully
better be
what is this position
wow that's so cool meeting that in the
end too
okay time is really being nice to me how
many games was that
six and a half plus so that's 19 so we
have two more games
okay um yeah let's play this opening
again
maybe i'll play this opening
uh like a russolimo type thing
i'm just kind of making things up but
this looks reasonable
so i want to play uh pawn f4 eventually
never mind i have to resort to a sad
pawn f3
yeah that's a good move have this move
i think it's okay i mean i'm a bit worse
here
down on time too
and just stay focused
um okay i can live with this
i'm going for h5
another one of these
oh good move
ah that's life okay so there's one more
i think the next game is the last game
okay final game
i all i want is one stafford gambit
but he's playing a lot of uh four nights
please take the pawn please okay let's
be aggressive
as aggressive as possible
i actually don't know what we got into
here it looks interesting
though i can live with this
oh final game okay
all right final game this is the finale
of the match
okay let's maybe go for a sack
interesting move put the rook in the
center pin the pawn
knight versus bishop knight is nice
making luft for the king
okay blockade artificial isolation
another blockade rookie five lifting a
rook
taking a pawn defending with a battery
f5 maybe coming yeah don't mind the rook
trade
g5 someday soon or g6 oh g6 is not
working
i can take it's risky
because he's gonna push upon but i
defend
what's going on here blockade again
maybe a6 preventing the bishop
okay i want a queen trade
please i want a queen trade let's bring
the king in
the king power in the end game let's go
oh but b5 let's go
oh oh my time but his time
what is this position e3 uh-oh it's a
time scramble again
straight queens let's go
okay move don't mate me
don't hurt me
stop hurting me stop it
yes okay
okay i think that's the end right
i think that's end
[Music]
thanks for the games yeah that was fun
uh shout out to my opponent who is also
streaming
um his twitch name is the same as his
leeches name
jvm to something mix
yeah people can check him out
oh look at this look at this
so i was playing hall of the mountain
king
uh look at this view count they're
almost at 20 million views